Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in the
audience at David Pakman dot com slash discord
and you can. Discord is free. I'm not
selling you anything other than a good time.
And we will hear from some people because if
you weren't here, it would be really weird.
Let's start with Ricky from Charlotte. Ricky,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I wanted to ask you about
two potential future scenarios that I think are
somewhat plausible and could give the left some
hope if they do happen, as want to see how likely
you thought they were. Okay. The first one being
around the Supreme Court. I see that it seems now
that the court is completely politicized, like all
the retirements will be super politicized while
the justices going forward. But I do wonder if we
could hope that Roberts is not as crazy as like
the Republican is, like, you know, the way the
Republicans are now. And he's and and it would
be conceivable that at some point he could retire
when there is a Democrat in office. I don't see
that happening with like Alito or Thomas or any
of the crazy ones. But Roberts is someone that I'm
holding up on. Do you think that could happen?
Speaker 1: I mean, sure, but he's only 67. So,
you know, if history is an indicator, it's
not happening anytime soon. It's not happening
soon enough that there's really any reason to
speculate now because it could be decades away.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean, 67 is I mean, you know,
maybe it could be like ten years from now. I mean,
you know, if he's been on the court
for like 20 years at this point,
I don't know. I think I saw like
the average justice are like around
20 years or something like that. So.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yeah. I mean, listen,
there's nothing we can do about it. It can't be
part of any kind of strategy, I guess is my point,
because we don't know when it would happen anyway.
Speaker 3: Yeah, but I just don't see that it
would happen with anyone else. And if it happened
with him, I feel like that would you know,
that could bode well for us. But okay, the
second one, I just want to ask my really quick,
um, if the, you know, Trump and DeSantis or
other Republicans go at it in the primary,
if Trump loses, I feel like he will do
another. It was rigged against me. And,
um, you know, the establishment is stealing
from me is like, stop the steal B.S.
I'm like, cause the Republicans are and see,
like, the same headaches that he's caused,
like the whole country and stuff. Do you see
that happening? Do you think if that did happen,
would he potentially run as a third party?
Speaker 1: No, I think I mean, maybe. But listen,
so here's the deal. Trump would never
win as a third party. And of course,
if Trump fights for the Republican nomination and
loses, he will say that it was rigged and stolen
from him by the rhinos. But then that'll be it.
You know, he'll be like almost 80 and he's not
going to run at age 84. And that that'll kind of
it'll be it. So yes, it'll be annoying and he'll
do it. But then then we'll be rid of Trump.
Speaker 3: Do you think that would damage
whoever the nominee is in that point
in like the Republicans, the general.
Speaker 1: If he ran as a third party candidate?
Speaker 3: No, no. If if he lost in like.
Speaker 1: Attacked the primary.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly.
Speaker 1: No, probably not.
Speaker 3: Thanks. Okay. I was hoping for.
Speaker 1: I think what would hurt Republicans
is just a really long and contentious primary.
I think that that would be bad for Republicans.
Speaker 3: Yeah, because I remember last time
before the primary, Ted Cruz actually
seemed like a politician that could win
the election. And after Trump played him, I
don't see him ever like winning. Now, I mean,
never say never. But he he seems like super
weak now, so. Anyway, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Ricky from Charlotte, thank
you so much. Very, very much. Appreciate that.